Donc la lettre aux Philippiens, c'est une lettre qui a été écrite par Paul vraiment très proche de la fin de sa vie, lorsqu'il était encore en prison.
Et nous pouvons constater par cette lettre que Paul était un homme véritablement joyeux.
Dans cette même lettre, il avoue qu'il a traversé et qu'il traverse encore quelques tristesses.
Mais c'est par cette lettre qu'il fait appel à cette église qui était très chère pour son cœur, à se réjouir toujours dans les seigneurs.
C'est impossible, humainement parlant, si on essaye d'étudier un cas comme celui de l'apôtre Paul, avec toutes les ressources et toutes les mesures que les mondes utilisent aujourd'hui pour considérer ce qui fait la joie humaine.
C'est impossible de comprendre par les paramètres humains, surtout corrompus, que cet homme-là était vraiment joyeux.
Et en même temps, c'est impossible de nier qu'il était quelqu'un de véritablement joyeux, car même dans une prison, en souffrant plein de privations,
il a la capacité d'enseigner à comment se réjouir et d'exhorter des personnes qui étaient en train de vivre une vie
et qui étaient en train de se réjouir.
C'est réjouir au sommet et exhorter les chrétiens à se réjouir.
Et donc, Paul était emprisonné, mais là, il recevait des nouvelles de plusieurs églises.
Cela faisait sa joie d'un côté et lui donnait aussi l'occasion de continuer à servir à l'éternel, d'édifier,
d'avoir une signification pour sa vie qui surmonte tous les autres buts ou objectifs qu'on puisse avoir dans cette vie,
toutes les autres vocations, si vous voulez.
Il pouvait, depuis une prison, contribuer à l'avancement de l'évangile, à l'édification, à l'affermissement des églises.
Il pouvait, dans cette prison, trouver par la prière la communion avec le Seigneur Jésus.
Il avait du temps pour méditer à l'évangile, pour étudier la Bible et les livres qu'il demande,
qu'on les ramène dans la prison.
Donc, il avait, dans ces cadres des prisons, en ayant été battu, en étant proche de sa mort,
il savait qu'il pouvait quand même faire avancer les rames des dieux.
Il pouvait avoir accès direct à la présence des dieux.
Et si jamais il serait mort, il pouvait avoir la rencontre sublime avec Dieu directement.
Être avec Christ était incomparablement mieux.
Mais s'il fallait rester ici-bas, dans une prison, il n'y avait rien qui manquait
pour qu'il puisse faire avancer les rames des dieux,
pour qu'il puisse grandir en joie, en santé, en conformité au caractère du Christ.
Et donc, l'apôtre Paul, quand il arrive au chapitre 3,
il nous présente les fondements ultimes de la joie chrétienne.
Donc, les chrétiens et la tristesse, c'est une contradiction,
car la joie chrétienne, elle est présentée comme la béatitude suprême.
Toutes les sources de plaisir qu'on aurait pu imaginer trouver ici-bas,
nous n'avons aucune assurance que dans cette vie nous l'aurons.
Donc, la joie d'aucune personne ne peut dépendre de ces choses.
Et même si les personnes avaient les mondes entiers,
et pas les salubles de leur âme, ça sera un grand vide,
car Dieu nous a créés pour lui.
Et la réjouissance de tous les biens de ces mondes ne peut pas faire la joie de l'être humain.
Il y a un vide toujours, lorsque les choses que Dieu a créées
pour maximiser notre relation avec lui,
non pas Dieu pour objectif suprême et principal.
La réjouissance des bonnes choses sans Dieu, c'est toujours très vide.
Mais les chrétiens ont non seulement l'assurance qu'il va hériter
toutes les bonnes choses de ces mondes perfectionnés,
il a aussi la certitude de pouvoir tout réjouir en commun avec Dieu,
et ayant pour cœur et pour sommet de toute la réjouissance
la relation avec les pères, avec les fils, avec Dieu lui-même.
Donc, ce qui est le sommet et le fondement ultime de la joie,
c'est quelque chose que ce n'est que les chrétiens qui peuvent goûter.
Et ils peuvent les goûter indépendamment des circonstances de cette vie.
Donc, l'apôtre Paul va manifester quel est le centre de sa joie au chapitre 3,
en verset 8, lorsqu'il dit
« L'excellence de la connaissance de Jésus-Christ, mon Seigneur ».
C'est un contexte où il avait présenté tout son crédit,
tout son succès, on va dire comme ça, temporel.
Mais lorsqu'il a comparé toute sa réussite à la connaissance du Christ,
à l'excellence, à la beauté, à la gloire de la connaissance du Seigneur Jésus-Christ,
il a trouvé la joie ultime dans la connaissance du Seigneur Jésus.
Ensuite, il va présenter un peu plus tard, dans les mêmes chapitres,
que la conformité avec les souffrances du Christ
produisait davantage la connaissance du Christ, la compréhension.
Donc, on sait que les Christs a souffert pour nous.
Nous savons que nous devons avoir une connaissance suffisante pour être sauvés
du fait qu'il a payé pour nos péchés.
Dieu peut nous pardonner car il nous a punis en Christ.
Sauf que personne ici ne connaît la mesure exacte de ce qu'on devrait souffrir.
De connaître ce que Christ a souffert à la croix,
c'est quelque chose que nous allons connaître pendant toute l'éternité.
Et le plus on comprend ce qu'il a supporté à la croix pour nous,
le plus on a de l'amour envers Dieu.
Et donc, cette idée d'une vie avec pyjama après la conversion,
d'une vie de prospérité terrestre après la conversion,
elle est à contre-courant de la didactique divine
pour nous faire comprendre et connaître davantage l'amour des dieux
révélé en Christ pour nous.
C'est cet amour qui a supporté la croix pour nous sauver,
pour nous pardonner.
Donc, l'apôtre Paul dit,
je peux compléter ce qui manque aux souffrances du Christ,
pas dans les sens où Christ n'a pas souffert suffisamment.
Ce n'est pas une souffrance expiatoire.
Christ a tout souffert à cet égard.
mais pour nous, pour notre sanctification,
pour qu'on puisse grandir en amour et en joie envers le Christ,
le plus on se conforme avec Christ,
non seulement dans sa vie,
dans son obéissance parfaite,
dans la beauté de sa vie,
dans cette obéissance qu'il a pu nous créditer
pour qu'on soit approuvés devant Dieu,
mais aussi la beauté de sa vie
en se laissant mourir pour produire la vie des autres,
en souffrant pour promouvoir l'évangile.
C'est cette conformité-là
qui nous fait comprendre davantage
combien Christ nous aime,
combien il aime son Église,
combien il est digne de notre adoration,
de notre reconnaissance, de notre amour.
Et cette conformité produisait,
chez l'apôtre Paul, de la joie.
Car pour lui,
remporter les prix dans cette vie,
c'était, dans ces temps qu'il reste,
au maximum qu'il est possible,
connaître davantage le Christ.
Dans la conformité avec sa belle vie,
son obéissance,
mais aussi dans la conformité avec ses souffrances.
En devant conforme à lui dans sa mort
pour ne pas vernir, si j'appuie,
à la résurrection entre les morts.
Pour l'apôtre Paul,
il a appris à embrasser
toutes les circonstances de la vie,
qui pouvaient l'apprendre
à réjouir d'une plus grande intimité,
donc il dit,
la communion de ses souffrances.
goûter l'intimité avec Jésus
par la souffrance.
Avoir une perception
que les douleurs qu'on traverse,
on les traverse en méritant encore plus,
mais Christ l'a traversée sans mériter aucune.
Et ensuite,
à la fin du chapitre 3,
il démontre aussi un autre aspect
de cette joie,
du fondement de cette joie.
Donc c'est la connaissance du Christ,
une connaissance par la conformité
en toutes circonstances.
Et le troisième aspect,
c'est la certitude
d'un héritage glorieux,
réservé en Christ.
Donc à chaque fois,
l'apôtre Paul va répéter l'expression
dans les seigneurs,
en Christ Jésus,
pour nous rappeler
que les fondements ultimes
de la joie,
c'est toujours le Christ.
Et au verset 20 du chapitre 3,
il dit,
mais notre cité à nous
est dans les cieux.
Donc l'attente n'est pas
de la patrie parfaite,
ici-bas,
les changements politiques
pour lesquels on doit
quand même lutter
pour préserver,
mais sans avoir
une attente exagérée.
Car notre joie
ne sera jamais trouvée
dans ces paradis perdus
sur terre.
Notre cité
est dans les cieux.
Notre cœur
Notre joie
est dans les cieux.
D'où nous attendons aussi
les Seveurs
et le Seigneur Jésus-Christ
qui transformera
les corps de notre humiliation.
Les corps qui est humilié
d'un côté
par sa temporalité,
par son éphémérité.
Les corps qui est aussi humilié
car dans ces corps
nous avons encore
les restes de la chair
et nous sommes
moralement,
constamment
déçus
avec notre performance morale.
Mais les jours
où le Seigneur
reviendra,
il va nous délivrer
de toute cette frustration
envers ses corps.
Les maladies,
la chair,
il va rendre
ses corps
semblables
au corps de sa gloire.
Mais c'est 21.
par les pouvoirs
qui est là
d'assujettir
toutes les choses.
Et donc,
nous avons cette assurance
que nous avons déjà tout.
On n'a plus besoin
de donner l'écoute
à cette hérésie dégoûtante
qu'est l'évangile
de la prospérité,
de décréter les choses.
que notre joie
soit toujours
dans l'espérance
du changement
des circonstances.
Nous sommes déjà
les personnes
les plus riches
de l'univers
pour toute l'éternité
et nous pouvons
pendant
ces pèlerinages éphémères
laisser de côté
certaines priorités
triviales
qui ne vont pas
avec une vie
qui devrait être marquée
par la période
des guerres,
des batailles spirituelles.
Et donc,
nous avons déjà
un héritage certain
qui nous attend
et au cœur
de cet héritage,
les sauveurs
et Seigneurs Jésus-Christ.
Par contre,
les seigneurs
et les sauveurs
Jésus-Christ,
il est proche,
il est présent,
il est déjà accessible,
il est en mission,
il est en train
de réussir
dans son agenda
dont son intérêt premier
c'est de faire avancer
son église.
Et pour nous,
les chrétiens,
nous allons retrouver
notre joie
lorsque nous allons
accorder nos agendas
à ses priorités.
Et donc,
l'apôtre Paul,
au chapitre 3,
nous donne
ses fondements ultimes
de la joie chrétienne
et au chapitre 4,
il commence
avec
ses mots,
c'est pourquoi
et là,
c'est,
voilà comment on apprend
à faire des sermons,
c'est d'en ayant
bien établi
la vérité centrale,
la doctrine,
si vous voulez,
en ayant
enraciné
nos pensées
dans une vérité
inébranlable,
poser la question
donc à la lumière
de cette vérité,
comment devons-nous vivre ?
L'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire
voici les fondements
ultimes de votre joie.
Donc,
comment devons-nous vivre
dans ces pèlerinages
éphémères
des manières
à maximiser
cette joie,
à anticiper
cette joie ?
Et donc,
ce que l'apôtre Paul
va faire
en faisant
beaucoup de répétitions
avec l'expression
« dans les seigneurs »
et aussi avec l'expression
« réjouissez-vous »
autrefois,
je vous dis
« réjouissez-vous »
c'est là
où nous allons apprendre
avec l'apôtre Paul
que ces fondements
ultimes de notre joie
qui sont surtout
centrés sur un avernier
certain futur,
cette joie,
elle peut déjà
dans les temps
qui nous restent
être maximisée
et réjouie
par plusieurs aires
de la vie chrétienne.
Le nouveau-né
a été créé
avec de nouveaux appétits,
avec un nouveau palais,
des nouveaux goûts.
Et l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles
on a beaucoup
de chrétiens
attristés
c'est car
ils ne cherchent pas
à satisfaire
les demandes
de leur nouvelle nature
avec la nourriture
qui satisfait vraiment.
On est souvent
très distrait
par les ambitions
de ces mondes
corrompues
et temporelles.
Et donc l'apôtre Paul
il dit
« vous avez déjà tout
donc vivez
ce qui vous reste
en cherchant
votre joie
dans ces aires-là.
Et donc
la vérité principale
pour nous
c'est que les fondements
ultimes
de la joie chrétienne
ont l'espérance
inébranlable
dans les seigneurs
qui a pour cœur
la vision béatifique
du Christ
dans le retour
du Seigneur
et par complément
la béatitude éternelle
un environnement parfait
un corps parfait
une moralité parfaite
en communion
avec Christ
dans un lieu parfait.
ayant cette espérance
inébranlable
dans les seigneurs
comme un craje
suprême
de notre joie
la question
qu'on se pose
pour les temps
qui nous restent
c'est
où pouvons-nous
expérimenter
cette joie
ou la joie
de cette même nature
pendant notre pèlerinage.
Nous avons déjà
considéré
deux aspects
pendant la retraite
nous allons considérer
un troisième aujourd'hui.
Le premier aspect
qu'on a considéré
c'est que
dans les seigneurs
pendant notre pèlerinage
nous avons pour source
des joies
l'amour fraternel
unis par
et pour les services
dans les seigneurs.
Donc le verset 1 à 5
l'apôtre Paul parle
c'est pourquoi
mes bien-aimés
et très chers frères
qui êtes ma joie
et ma couronne
d'aimer ainsi ferme
dans les seigneurs
mes bien-aimés.
Donc ici
ce sont des expressions
répétitives et profondes
d'affection et des joies
que l'apôtre Paul
a pris dans cette église
qui a été sa première
implantée
et un niveau
si authentique
d'intimité
et d'affection
qu'il répète
bien-aimés deux fois
et qu'il fait
ses déclarations
vous êtes ma joie
vous êtes ma couronne
comme s'il disait
vous êtes les sceaux
quelque part
de mon apostolat.
Moi j'étais
comme un père spirituel
qui vous est engendré
avec les douleurs
d'enfantement
car beaucoup
Paul a beaucoup
souffert
lorsqu'il a implanté
ces églises
et particulièrement
l'église des Philippiens.
Il a été battu
il a été emprisonné
et il a persévéré.
Et on voit
comment il dit
vous êtes ma joie
car ils sont
une église ferme.
Donc ici
pour nous
c'est de nous rappeler
comme on a fait
que c'est impossible
aux vrais chrétiens
de trouver leur joie
dans cette vie
séparés
de la communion
avec l'église
séparés
de la fraternité
entre les frères et sœurs.
Dieu
est un Dieu famille
il ne nous sauve
jamais dans un vide
dans une anarchie
il nous sauve
dans l'église
envers l'église
et pour plus
qu'on a aussi appris
de la part de Jésus
qu'on allait avoir
beaucoup des synagogues
de Satan
des fausses églises
ces corruptions extrêmes
ne nous donnent jamais
l'excuse
de ne pas chercher
ce que la Bible
ponte envers tous les chrétiens
comme l'environnement
de leur joie.
L'essence des privilèges
de pouvoir
être utilisé
par Dieu
dans les saluts
et dans l'édification
des frères
et recevoir des frères
des moyens
et des manifestations
d'affection
et d'édification
également.
Et c'est une joie
vraiment très authentique
et sincère
car on voit
dans ses versets aussi
que l'apôtre Paul
doit exhorter
deux sœurs
qui avaient servi
avec lui
à la réconciliation.
Donc la joie
dans les cadres
de la fraternité
n'est pas
une joie superficielle
où nous gardons
une distance
dans nos relations.
C'est une joie
retrouvée
dans l'approfondissement
de nos liens
à travers les services
pour l'évangile
et pas dans des activités
qui peuvent sembler
comme un club
de l'église parfois.
Mais nous allons
servir ensemble
et en servissant
ensemble
ou en servant ensemble
pardon
nous allons
approfondir
nos relations
et trouver la joie
approfondir
notre amour.
Par contre
nous sommes
un parfait
et pour mieux
qu'on cherche
à servir ensemble
nous pouvons avoir
des divergences
les manifestations
de nos faiblesses
et la division
peut avoir lieu.
L'église
étant appelée
les lieux
de la réconciliation
l'évangile
étant connu
comme l'évangile
de la réconciliation
les christs
sont appelés
les princes
de la paix
et les chrétiens
étant appelés
fils des dieux
lorsqu'ils nous
procurons la paix
nous savons
que dans l'ADN
de toute église
c'est pas
l'absence totale
des divisions
qu'on doit trouver
mais une prédisposition
infiniment supérieure
à chercher
la réconciliation
et à préserver
l'unité.
Et donc
l'apôtre Paul ici
il fait appel
à la réconciliation
et donc
c'est une église
qui est mature
et qui va maturer
car elle va comparer
les petites divisions
sous la perspective
de ce qu'ils ont déjà
fait ensemble
pour les seigneurs
et ce qu'ils peuvent
encore faire ensemble
pour les seigneurs
et Paul va ajouter
car le seigneur
est prêt
est proche
donc le seigneur
il est là
il n'est pas intéressé
aux divisions
le seigneur
il est là
il revient bientôt
et donc
au lieu de perdre du temps
soyons efficaces
envers l'évangélisation
car la douceur
chez les chrétiens
doit être
une marque distinctive
envers l'évangélisation
des perdus
une église en division
est un très mauvais témoignage
pour l'évangélisation
des perdus
et donc
que votre douceur
soit connue
de tous les hommes
c'est dire
mettez la priorité
du royaume des dieux
au-dessus
de toutes vos différences
réconciliez-vous
vite
le seigneur
revient vite
vous êtes en train
de perdre du temps
au lieu de faire
quelque chose
de significatif
pour l'avancement
du royaume
l'un des plus grands
ennemis de l'église
dans nos jours
c'est la manière
dont les chrétiens
cherchent à traiter
leurs différences
leurs désaccords
comme des chiens
qui se disputent
sur internet
les personnes
cherchent à exposer
à diffamer
même
à cause des désaccords
et ils sont en train
de tellement jouer
et manipuler
par Satan
pour créer
de la division
et parfois
ce sont des personnes
qui n'ont même pas
cet historique
c'est-à-dire
ils n'ont pas d'histoire
ils n'ont implanté
aucune église
ils n'ont pas servi
l'évangile ensemble
avec coopération
comme Paul peut parler
évodie, senti
qu'il pouvait être
connu
car c'était quand même
des femmes
qui ont servi
officiellement
en tant que compagnons
de l'apôtre Paul
et de ses compagnons
mais comme l'internet
devient une plateforme
très facile
à voir du public
surtout par la polémique
ces très mauvais
représentants parasitaires
de l'évangile
jouent plus contre
les rogues de Dieu
que pour les rogues de Dieu
par contre
une église
responsable
plus tôt ou plus tard
doit intervenir
Paul appelle
ses compagnons d'oeuvre
à intervenir
et nous voyons
en fait
la relation
entre
une fraternité
avec des liens
véritables
qui apprennent
ensemble
non seulement
à servir
mais à surmonter
leur différence
par la douceur
avec amour
le deuxième point
dans lequel
nous retrouvons la joie
c'est la prière
communautaire
qui rénovait
la paix dans les seigneurs
donc ici c'est très intéressant
donc l'unité
de l'église
de la fraternité
elle est très importante
mais du verset 6
jusqu'au verset
verset 6 et 7
nous allons retrouver aussi
l'importance
de la prière
donc l'apôtre Paul dit
ne vous inquiétez
des riant
mais en toute chose
faites connaître
vos besoins
à Dieu
par des prières
des supplications
avec des actions
des grâces
et la paix
des dieux
qui surpassent
toute intelligence
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
donc en Jésus Christ
à nouveau
et une expression
qui devient
le synonyme
de la joie
car sans paix
il n'y a pas de joie
quelqu'un dit
que la paix
ou la joie
est la paix
qui danse
l'apôtre Paul ici
il va mettre
en contraste aussi
c'est qu'il y a
l'opposé de la joie
c'est l'inquiétude
l'anxiété
et ici
il donne comme un impératif
ne vous inquiétez
de rien
c'est un ordre
lorsqu'il y a
Dieu
qui donne
un ordre
aux chrétiens
c'est car
Dieu lui-même
est capable
de corroborer
de supporter
cet ordre
de payer
de sponsoriser
si on peut dire
comme ça
les prières
sont les remèdes
immédiats
pour l'anxiété
à combien de reprises
on va retrouver
en David
qui commence
plusieurs psaumes
en détresse
parfois même
en désespoir
au bord du désespoir
et qui sort
et finit les psaumes
en se réjouissant
dans les seigneurs
en louant les seigneurs
ici
il faut prier
en tout temps
en tout lieu
et les manques
de paix
c'est égal
au manque
de joie
et malheureusement
ce que ces mondes
trouvent aujourd'hui
sont des palliatifs
insuffisants
qui ne règlent
jamais les problèmes
à la racine
car ils n'ont pas
la capacité
nous les chrétiens
tout comme les non-chrétiens
nous vivons dans un monde
par rapport auquel
on n'a pas les contrôles
des circonstances
nous sommes fragiles
on est entourés
des menaces
on est humiliés
moralement
par nous-mêmes
par notre fragilité
par notre santé
et exposés
et lorsque l'imagination
humaine
corrompue
donne des ailes
à ces circonstances
difficiles
l'aberration
entre l'humanité
n'est pas
celui qui est
crantif
les fous
c'est celui
qui n'a pas
des crises
d'anxiété
quand on considère
la fragilité
humaine
les menaces
qui nous entourent
et les faits
que nous savons
au fond de notre conscience
qu'on ne mérite pas
la faveur des dieux
donc l'idée
d'un dieu contre nous
devait s'emparer
de la conscience
de tous les êtres humains
sauf
les chrétiens
donc pour nous
c'est différent
les autres
vont chercher
dans des conforts
insensés
à oublier
leurs problèmes
les drogues
les distractions
les divertissements
ils n'arrivent pas
à se serrer
dans leur chambre
pour écouter
leurs propres pensées
ils tombent vite
dans la panique
dans les désespoirs
mais les chrétiens
c'est l'opposé
et pourquoi
car les chrétiens
ils peuvent faire
recours
non aux vibrations
positives
aveugles
ou à la mentalisation
du changement
des circonstances
nous pouvons aller
directement
à la salle du trône
et c'est lui
qui gouverne
tous les atomes
de l'univers
c'est
autodéclaré
notre terre
qui gouverne
toutes les circonstances
pour nous faire
connaître davantage
son amour
et nous conformer
à la sainteté
de son fils
donc les chrétiens
il n'est pas livré
aux forces aveugles
de l'univers
au hasard
les chrétiens
a toute sa vie calculée
même les cheveux
de sa tête
par un dieu
qui a tout déterminé
pour produire
Christ en nous
et comment nous pouvons
renouveler
notre pensée
dans un premier moment
la première chose
à faire
c'est
de vouloir
et ça devrait être
une caractéristique
de tous les chrétiens
pas de sortir
nos portables
pour rester
deux trois heures
chez Instagram
pour nous distraire
avant de dormir
c'est de nous serrer
dans notre chambre
et passer du temps
avec notre Père Céleste
qu'elle a la raison
parfois
du manque de joie
chez les chrétiens
tout simplement
il manque de prière
en toute chose
faites connaître à Dieu
vos besoins
non seulement
les nécessités
mais
les désirs
les pétitions
les attentes
et ce qui est intéressant
c'est
qu'on est en train
de faire connaître
à Dieu
au Tout-Puissant
par des prières
des supplications
donc plusieurs formes
de prières
donc ici
ça présuppose
vraiment du temps
passé dans la prière
ça présuppose
la variété
des formes
des prières
mais particulièrement
les actions des grâces
car la plus grande
bénédiction
soit avec moi
la plus grande
bénédiction
qu'on va retrouver
dans la prière
n'est pas
les changements
des circonstances
vous êtes avec moi
la plus grande
bénédiction
qu'on retrouve
dans la prière
c'est les contentements
en Dieu
regardez
il dit ici
par des prières
des supplications
avec action
des grâces
on est en train
de se supplier
de décharger
sur Dieu
nos désirs
nos attentes
nos préoccupations
et une fois
qu'on l'a fait
on peut se reposer
on a de toute manière
aucun contrôle
sur ces choses
mais une fois
qu'on a fait connaître
à notre papa
pour notre bien
donc c'est
très thérapeutique
mais c'est par la thérapie
du divan
car il y a quelque chose
de thérapeutique
dans le divan
rien que de se faire entendre
rien que de mettre
à l'extérieur
mais Dieu les connait déjà
c'est pour nous
sauf que là
on n'est pas en train
de donner nos problèmes
à quelqu'un
qu'on sait très bien
qui n'a aucune capacité
de régler
là on est en train
de livrer
dans les mains
de notre Père
qui est le Tout-Puissant
et qu'elle est
le résultat
ultime
de la prière
n'est pas l'assurance
des changements
des circonstances
on n'est pas
par la prière
en train de devenir
les conseillers de Dieu
pour dire Dieu
je voulais te suggérer
car si tu changes
certaines choses
dans ma vie
ça serait mieux
pour moi
qui sommes-nous
pour douter
des chemins
des dieux
pour conseiller
Dieu
et ce qui est
le mieux
pour nous-mêmes
c'est lui
notre Père
l'omniscient
qui a la connaissance
et toutes les choses
et de la manière
dont il va produire
véritablement
notre vraie joie
dans la prière
on se décharge
et on se repose
et quels sont les résultats
ultimes
pas les changements
de circonstances
mais la paix
des dieux
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
la paix des dieux
qui surpasse
toute l'intelligence
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
pourquoi ?
avoir la paix
des dieux
c'est d'avoir
toute la paix
au monde
car les problèmes
radicals
de l'être humain
même si on pense
qu'on est bien
parfois
dans nos vies
si nous n'avons pas
la paix
avec Dieu
on n'a pas
la capacité
de plaider
contre les justes juges
les justes juges
omnisciens
quelle est la raison
ultime
de toute la détresse
humaine
c'est que même
lorsqu'ils réjouissent
de certaines bonnes choses
dans cette vie
ils n'ont pas la paix
car leur conscience
sait que
plus tôt ou plus tard
ils vont devoir
rendre compte à Dieu
sauf que
nous qui avons déjà
connu radicalement
la paix des dieux
nous savons
que la paix des dieux
suffit
pour produire la paix
envers toutes les circonstances
c'est lorsqu'on était encore
ennemi des dieux
il a envoyé son fils
pour régler notre problème
d'inimitié envers Dieu
c'est clair
qu'il peut nous donner
avec lui toutes les choses
si nous sommes réconciliés
avec Dieu
les saints
c'est lui qui
a la gouvernance
de toutes les circonstances
nous pouvons être sûrs
que nous ne devons
attendre
aucune chose
de mauvaise
de ce qu'il a réservé
pour nous
ce sont des
bénédictions déguisées
ce sont des difficultés
qu'il assure
qu'on a la capacité
d'enlever
d'être traversé
car même la perte
pour nous est un gant
car il nous fait connaître
davantage Dieu
et nous conformer
plus avec les Christs
donc ayant été réconcilié
avec Dieu
c'est lui qui détient
les contrôles
de tout l'univers
de toutes les circonstances
les dieux souverains
ayant été réconcilié
avec lui
il faut savoir
que toutes les choses
concourent à notre bien
et lorsqu'on considère
de quelle manière
il a pourvu cette perte
quand on voit
comment les Christs
a été la manière
par laquelle Dieu
nous a réconciliés
avec lui
on peut être sûr
que nous n'avons aucun droit
de douter
ni des bonnes intentions
de Dieu
ni de l'amour de Dieu
ni de la toute puissance
de Dieu
ni de la sagesse
Dieu n'a plus
aucune raison
d'être défavorable
envers les Chrétiens
pourquoi ?
car Christ
a vécu parfaitement
la vie
qu'on devrait vivre
qu'on n'arrive pas à vivre
d'obéissance
donc à notre place
Christ a présenté à Dieu
son obéissance parfaite
et par là
il a conquis les droits
de demander à Dieu
qu'il nous bénisse
et il a été puni
aussi
parfaitement
par tous nos péchés
passés, présents, futurs
aucune dette
reste envers Dieu
pour que Dieu
ne soit pas
favorable
envers nous
si c'est une paix
qui surpasse
toute l'intelligence
d'un côté
car
nous n'allons
jamais avoir
la capacité
de mesurer
ou d'évaluer
ce que Christ
a produit
en termes
de réconciliation
avec Dieu
les détenteurs
de toute la puissance
de tous les domaines
de l'univers
les propriétaires
de toutes les choses
si nous sommes réconciliés
en Christ
avec Dieu
tout est à nous
vous êtes avec moi
c'est une paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
car
pour plus
que l'intelligence
nous aide
à contempler
les raisons
de cette paix
elle sera toujours
limitée
car on n'aura jamais
la capacité
de calculer
combien Dieu
émane
cette paix
envers nous
combien Dieu
veut
que nous soyons
en paix
combien
contre-intuitive
c'est de ne pas
avoir la paix
en étant chrétien
c'est une paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
car on n'a pas
la capacité
de mesurer
la vie parfaite
que Christ a vécue
pour nous
pour conquérir
tout ce que Dieu
veut nous bénir
et la punition
qu'il a souffert
pour payer
pour notre désobéissance
c'est une paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
bien sûr aussi
car l'intelligence
humaine
livrée à soi-même
n'a jamais
la capacité
de promouvoir
ni de produire
la psychanalyse
moderne
peut essayer
de vous dire
qu'il faut
suivre vos sentiments
ça ne va pas
produire la paix
car la conscience
ne va pas permettre
cette paix
n'est pas trouvée
dans aucune
grande école
de l'univers
aucun philosophe
n'a jamais
rédigé quelque chose
qui puisse produire
la vraie paix
toutes les attentes
après la révolution
industrielle
envers la paix
et donc
la joie
s'est portée
envers la civilité
et c'est notamment
après tout
cet espoir
envers la civilité
ou l'humanisme
qu'on arrive
aux deux grandes guerres
mondiales
c'est la paix
des dieux
avec dieu
et c'est la paix
que dieu communique
c'est la paix
que dieu assure
qui encadre
la vie chrétienne
c'est une paix
qui ne peut pas
être dérobée
par les menaces
ni par la prison
et c'est la paix
profondément
espérimentale
car
une fois
qu'on a compris
l'évangile
cette paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
fait que
dès que nos cœurs
car
les manques de paix
c'est une maladie
d'affection
d'avoir
développé une passion
idolâtre
envers des choses
qui ne sont pas pour nous
et qui n'ont pas
la capacité de nous plaire
et qui dieu ne veut pas
donner à ceux
qui développeront
une relation idolâtre
avec certaines bénédictions
c'est une affection
fixée
en Jésus Christ
la paix
des dieux
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
c'est une paix
qui va dominer
impréguer nos affections
c'est une paix
qui va dominer
et impréguer nos pensées
car nos affections
et nos pensées
seront fixées
en Jésus Christ
les seuls objets
capables
de porter la paix
de produire la joie
et c'est profondément
expérimental
la paix
qui surpasse
toute notre religion
ça passe par la raison
ça va au-delà
de la raison
ça s'empare
de notre tout
de nos affections
de notre joie
et lorsque
l'apôtre Paul
est dans une prison
menacée des morts
va bientôt mourir
et qu'il peut parler
dans ses termes
il est en train
de démontrer
de manière très claire
c'est la paix
qu'il expérimente
c'est la joie
par la prière
dans une prison
il a des expériences
profondes
avec ses affections
ses pensées
imprégnées
de la communion
avec Jésus Christ
et il est visité
par une paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
l'intelligence humaine
regarde ces circonstances
il dit
c'est impossible
qu'il soit dans la joie
et lui
répond en écrivant
sous inspiration divine
ses versets
et le troisième aspect
c'est le que je veux voir
aujourd'hui avec vous
c'est que la sanctification
opérante
est aussi
l'une des principales
sources de joie
pour les chrétiens
la sanctification opérante
du Christ
qui promeut
l'intimité
avec Dieu
il dit
et la paix
qui surpasse
toute intelligence
gardera vos cœurs
et vos pensées
en Jésus Christ
vous êtes avec moi
le Christ
donc l'objet
de notre contemplation
qui doit s'emparer
de nos pensées
verset 8
au reste
frère
que tout ce qui est vrai
tout ce qui est honorable
tout ce qui est juste
tout ce qui est pur
tout ce qui est aimable
tout ce qui mérite
l'approbation
s'il y a quelques vertus
et s'il y a quelques louanges
que c'est là
au coup de vos pensées
ce que vous avez appris
reçu
et entendu
de moi
et ce que vous avez
vu en moi
pratiquez-le
et le Dieu
de la paix
sera avec vous
par la prière
la paix des dieux
par la sanctification
par l'obéissance
opérante
par l'imitation
du Christ
les dieux
de la paix
la paix des dieux
les dieux de la paix
c'est très important
de rappeler
ici nous sommes devant
l'une des promesses
les plus belles des écritures
et c'est pas qu'ici
que nous la retrouvons
qui nous enseigne
que nous allons
expérimenter
de plus en plus
la présence
des dieux
qui fait notre joie suprême
de plus en plus
que nous soyons
en train de progresser
en sanctification
pourquoi
les chrétiens
ne sont pas plus joyeux
car
les chrétiens
très souvent
ne sont pas plus sains
ils sont pas
déterminés
résolus
c'est pas ce qui occupe
leur pensée
de satisfaire
cette demande
qui est
la demande
décrite par Christ
dans la béatitude
comme la plus profonde
de l'âme humaine
heureux ceux qui ont
la faim
et la soif
des justices
car ils seront
rassasiés
impossible
à un chrétien
de trouver la joie
tout en restant
en péché
et nous ne pouvons
jamais confondre
cette prédisposition
des dieux
à nous pardonner
complètement
à cause
de l'oeuvre
du Christ
avec
l'intérêt
des dieux
de nous sanctifier
Dieu ne va
jamais
rejeter
un coeur
brisé
qui est honnête
par rapport
à ses batailles
spirituelles
ses batailles
contre la chair
la voie
des réprobations
lorsqu'on pêche
elle vient
de Satan
et pas de Jésus
car lorsqu'il
crie
sous le Saint-Esprit
vient nous confronter
c'est toujours
en nous donnant
de l'espoir
mais la Bible
nous enseigne
très clairement
que la même grâce
qui nous pardonne
qui nous accueille
c'est cette grâce
très intéressée
à nous sanctifier
quel père
peut avoir
envers ses enfants
l'objectif
ou l'intérêt
de leur convaincre
tout simplement
de l'amour
qu'il a
pour ses enfants
en dépit
de leur mauvais comportement
et nous sommes sûrs
qu'il y a Dieu
un Christ
si nous sommes
des vrais enfants
de Dieu
et il nous aime
en dépit
de nos mauvais comportements
envers les saluts
mais à partir du moment
où on a été
véritablement convertis
si nous sommes
c'est clair
que l'ambition
du fils pardonné
et l'ambition
du père
qui sauve
c'est de former
en nous
des raisons
pour que Dieu
puisse nous dire
le plus souvent possible
pas tout simplement
je t'aime malgré toi
mais de dire
comme il a dit
à son fils
voici
mon fils
bien aimé
en qui j'ai mis
toute mon affection
Dieu nous aime
comme à des enfants
si nous sommes
véritablement convertis
par la foi
à Jésus Christ
mais
il ne prend pas
plaisir
dans toute notre
manière de vivre
tous les temps
et l'ambition
du chrétien
et la joie
se trouve
dans la sanctification
et donc ici
nous voyons
de manière très claire
c'est une
sanctification opérante
et opérante
non seulement
en termes
des progressions
en pureté
et en conformité
avec
la moralité
du Christ
mais une progression
aussi
envers
la pratique
la vie
et la promotion
du roi des dieux
donc c'est que
l'apôtre Paul
est en train de dire ici
et ici c'est très intéressant
aussi
c'est que la progression
en sanctification
elle va toucher
tous les aspects
de la spiritualité
les affections
les pensées
et les actions
mais remarquez bien
en fait
la prééminence
du raisonnement
dans la foi chrétienne
la prééminence
de la réflexion
de la résolution
que ces choses
soient
ce qui occupe
votre pensée
donc
ici nous voyons
cette relation
entre joie
et sanctification
Dieu nous a appelé
à être saint
Dieu ne nous a jamais
appelé
à chercher
la joie directement
pour qu'on ne soit pas
trompé
et qu'on cherche
par les plaisirs
charnels
la joie
mais
nous nous nourrissons
comme l'écrit
c'est nourri
de la volonté
de Dieu
et en progressant
s'entêté
notre joie
progresse
et grandit
toute la spiritualité
doit être imprégnée
par la contemplation
du Christ
et la communion
avec l'écrit
donc la prière
elle est très importante
mais vous allez remarquer
dans ces versets
que la prière
n'est plus mentionnée
mais beaucoup prier
sans trop réfléchir
ne sert pas à grande chose
il faut que notre prière
soit imprégnée
des vérités bibliques
et de trop réfléchir
sans prier
ça nous fera
manquer
de la puissance
mais en plus
de réfléchir
et de prier
on doit agir aussi
et donc ici
nous voyons
l'importance
de la prière
de la contemplation
de la réflexion
de l'observation
de l'action
c'est ça
qui fait la sainteté
vous êtes avec moi ?
donc on commence
par la contemplation
de celui
qui par la prière
garde nos cœurs
et nos pensées
en Jésus Christ
donc ça va encadrer
de manière très claire
de quelle vertu
l'apôtre Paul
il parle
lorsqu'il parle
de tout ce qui est vrai
honorable
juste
pour faire vraiment
très court
c'est si nous sommes
authentiquement
d'avoir
nos cœurs
gardés en Christ
nos affections
gardées en Christ
et nos pensées
dirigées vers Christ
si nous sommes
en train de contempler
le Christ constamment
c'est impossible
que nos vies
ne soient pas marquées
par cette voie
la voie
qui est la voie
de suivre les pas
du Seigneur Jésus
c'est la loi
du Christ
comment
pourrais-moi
dire
que je suis
véritablement
en intimité
avec Christ
qui est l'objet
de mes affections
et de mes pensées
si la manière
dont je vis
ou les décisions
que je vais prendre
ne sont pas
vraies
honorables
justes
pur
aimables
etc
vous êtes avec moi
la contemplation
du Seigneur Jésus
est la racine
de cette vie
mais ça peut
devenir vraiment
très théorique
très spirituel
et ce qui est intéressant
c'est que Dieu
dans sa parole
on était en train
d'étudier
lévitique
cette semaine
avec Béa
et en lévitique
je dis
qu'il ne faut pas
être injuste
et après
il va rajouter
ni dans la mesure
ni dans les bâtons
ou les mètres
et donc il va détailler
plusieurs aspects
pour qu'il y ait
les moindres risques
de ne pas être précis
vis-à-vis
à la manière
dont on doit agir
vous êtes avec moi ?
et donc ici
c'est la même chose
il garde nos cœurs
et nos pensées
à Jésus-Christ
et donc
par la contemplation
du Christ
par l'observation
attentive
je vais chercher
à contempler sa vie
et me demander
devant
chaque opportunité
devant chaque pas
dans ma vie
comment je peux vivre
exactement
tel que lui
et donc l'apôtre Paul
pour être généreux
on va
on va dire
nommer
certaines choses
pour qu'on sache
qu'une authentique
contemplation du Christ
s'est reproduite
dans ma vie
voilà pourquoi
en plus
de contempler le Christ
on doit aussi
remplir nos pensées
de ces manières
particulières
par rapport à laquelle
le Christ
a vécu sa vie
et donc
c'est important
de nous rappeler
que le manque
des joies
des chrétiens
parfois
c'est par un manque
des réflexions
la vie vient
avec un bâton
et nous frappe à la tête
et nous sommes
exposés
dans notre fragilité
si
la réaction
des chrétiens
est toujours
très défaitiste
pauvre moi
victime
parce que Christ
nous a appris
d'avance
qu'il fallait attendre
les difficultés
malheureusement
aujourd'hui
les chrétiens
sont plutôt en train
d'opposer
dissocier
ou déséquilibrer
l'expérimental
du rationnel
ils vont se retraiter
parfois devant
la difficulté
et ne fait que prier
jusqu'à ce qu'ils
se sentent mieux
je dois ressentir
quelque chose
où nous sommes
devant une décision
difficile à prendre
car il nous semble
parfois que
toutes les voies
sont corrompues
demandent
de l'impureté
de la tâche
de notre part
ou des choses
apparemment triviales
comme
déclarer nos impôts
les difficultés
se manifestent
de plus en plus
les tempêtes
sont là
et les chrétiens
sont tentés
à se laisser gouverner
plus
par ce qui marche
ou par ces sentiments
que par la vérité
ou la raison
illuminée
par la parole
de Dieu
et donc
quel est
le progrès
envers la sanctification
ça commence par
les réflexions
les résolutions
on prend
Jonathan Edwards
17 ans
qui va faire
ses résolutions
la manière
dont il est
déterminé
à vivre
avant
de contempler
peu importe
ce que les circonstances
puissent apporter
il est déjà
résolu
à avoir
comme dit Esaïe
un visage
comme celui
d'un cailleux
d'un rocher
comme ces navires
qui vont naviguer
peu importe
quelles sont les circonstances
car il a été préparé
à percuter les vagues
sans perdre
son stabilité
tout autour
de nous
peut changer
mais non
notre caractère
sang est chrétien
donc la manque
des joies chrétiennes
parfois
c'est manque
de réflexion
ok
toute la vie
sans me donner
l'impression
que Dieu
est contre moi
est-ce que cela
est possible
selon l'enseignement
biblique
non
ça peut être
la manifestation
de l'enfer
contre ma vie
et peut-être
qu'il est en train
de confirmer
plutôt que je suis
dans la bonne voie
car si Satan
est si intéressé
à s'opposer
c'est peut-être
car je suis en train
de faire quelque chose
de pertinent
ça peut être
tout simplement
les difficultés
auxquelles nous sommes
tous exposés
et par là
Dieu va travailler
mon endurance
ma sanctification
il veut m'approcher
de lui
et j'avance
avec intégrité
le problème
c'est que
comme on n'est pas
en train de remplir
nos pensées
des bonnes choses
et c'est une bataille
surtout dans la pensée
quand on est exposé
à des doutes
à des crises
envers l'assurance
de salut
etc
on a
des souvenirs
qui ne sont pas
complètement effacés
de notre vie
de prégrès
de nos péchés passés
on a des tentations
qui nous surviennent
la bataille
elle commence là
dans la pensée
et si
même si on n'a pas
la capacité
d'empêcher
que les oiseaux
volent sur nos têtes
car parfois
ce sont même
les flèches des satan
ce ne sont même pas
nos pensées
qui nous gênent
mais des flèches
des satan
et même si on ne peut pas
s'empêcher
de recevoir
ces attaques
ou ces mémoires
de la chair
nous pouvons
empêcher
que les oiseaux
fassent des nids
sur nos têtes
et donc
il faut réagir vite
mais la manière
la plus efficace
dans la bataille
des pensées
n'est pas si tant
de chercher
à s'opposer
aux mauvaises pensées
mais c'est
d'imprégner
et d'occuper
nos pensées
avec les bonnes choses
imaginez-vous
si l'apôtre Paul
dans cette prison
serait plus accroché
à trouver
sa liberté
que de saisir
toutes les occasions
que Dieu était
en train de lui donner
pour qu'il puisse
approfondir
sa connaissance du Christ
pour qu'il puisse
occuper ses pensées
déchaussantes
des vertus
et
comprendre
de la part de Dieu
comment cette prison
pourrait être
une bénédiction
pour l'église
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
car nous n'avons
qu'à cette lettre
car Paul était emprisonné
il faut élargir
notre vision
en occupant
et en renouvelant
nos pensées
avec les pensées
du Seigneur
donc il a imprégné
ses pensées
et ses vertus
plus tard il va dire
ce que vous avez vu
en moi
et ce que cela signifie
c'est que quelque part
il était aussi
une incarnation
visible
de ses vertus
et ce qu'il va présenter ici
ce sont des voies
saintes
qui affichent
ce qu'il y a
en homme joyeux
un homme joyeux
c'est un homme
une femme
qui prenne plaisir
dans la piété
et qui essaye
de déterminer
en avance
sans dépendre
des circonstances
de comment
nous allons
vivre
nous avons
des décisions
à prendre
ou nous allons
peut-être
déménager
est-ce qu'on va
habiter plus proche
de l'église
ou pas
ou quelle procédure
est légitime
pour nous
en tant qu'église
à prendre
si nous voulons
acheter un bâtiment
lorsque quelques propositions
pour régler l'affaire
peuvent apporter
des tâches
ce n'est pas
une voie
pour nous
vous comprenez
donc ici
il commence par la vérité
au reste frère
tout ce qui est vrai
que cela occupe
votre pensée
tout ce qui est
conforme
tout ce qui honore
ou s'accorde
à la vérité
de Dieu
Dieu a révélé
la vérité
dans sa parole
ta parole
est la vérité
parce que Paul
a dit à Timothée
de tenir ferme
son témoignage
il dit
fasse la bonne profession
comme Jésus
a fait la bonne profession
devant Panspilac
des choses
qu'on ne peut pas
négocier
il n'y a pas
de vraie unité
entre les églises
sans la vérité
voilà pourquoi
Paul l'a dit
si même moi-même
ou un ange
présente
un autre évangile
qui soit anathème
la seule voie
des réconciliations
entre Dieu
et les hommes
les seuls noms
envers lesquels
on doit invoquer
pour cette réconciliation
c'est le Seigneur Jésus Christ
avec les faits
de l'évangile
les dieux
hommes
incarnés
nés d'une vierge
qui a vécu
une vie parfaite
à notre place
qui a mort à la croix
qui a ressuscité
et monté au ciel
les faits de l'évangile
c'était les faits
que l'apôtre Paul
a communiqué
donc
nous devons faire attention
dans la génération
contre
cette nouvelle
vague d'écuménisme
envers les catholicismes
romans
qui
a régné la foi
lorsqu'ils ont ajouté
l'autorité papale
à l'inspiration biblique
et qui ont
refusé
le fait
que les saluts
se donnent
qu'est par la foi
seule
à travers Jésus seul
c'est pas par nos oeuvres
que nous allons
conquérir les saluts
ou maintenir la foi
donc la vérité
des dieux
c'est quelque chose
qui doit déterminer
nos choix
nos décisions
nos résolutions
la vérité
dans la finalité
de nos vies
la vérité
dans l'attitude
et avec les moyens
l'autre jour
j'ai entendu
un témoignage
de quelqu'un
qui avait pour stratégie
invité des personnes
pour venir manger
quelque chose
chez lui
et par surprise
lorsque la personne
arrivait
c'était une réunion
d'évangélisation
de l'église
la finalité
était bonne
mais les moyens
n'étaient pas véritables
ils n'étaient pas
transparents
intègres
et là
Paul n'est pas
en train de dire
ce qui occupe
votre pensée
soit votre ressenti
c'est pas pour
suggérer
que les ressentis
soient
quelque part
les départages
des décisions
qu'on va prendre
et malheureusement
il y a une personne
qui n'arrive même pas
dans nos jours
à conseiller leurs enfants
car ils semblent faire
plus de confiance
à leur stratégie
pour éduquer leurs enfants
que ce que Dieu
a révélé
dans sa parole
la vérité
de Dieu
doit déterminer
et Dieu
honore
sa vérité
tout ce qui est honorable
c'est à dire
tout ce qui est
plein de dignité
tout ce qui
représente
ce qui est beau
ce qui est respectable
ce qui est révérend
donc lorsqu'on va
prendre une décision
ou qu'on va se porter
ou lorsque
les options sont
présentées devant nous
on doit agir
d'une manière
dans une génération
corrompue
qui soit
une manière
honorable
nous devons
prendre des décisions
dignes
d'être honorés
quand on contemple
la manière
dont l'Écrit
s'est vécu
on voit
qu'il a
manifesté
une vie
qui était
très équilibrée
très symétrique
mais caractérisée
par la révérence
même lorsqu'il parlait
à Dieu
il disait
père sain
père juste
il n'y a pas
d'intimité
meuleuse
avec les seigneurs
l'attitude
ou la vie
honorable
elle est revêtue
ou l'honneur
est la manière
de revêtir
la dignité
appropriée
à la position
ou au caractère
d'une personne
nous sommes des chrétiens
nous pouvons avoir
des estimes différents
ok
mais nous devons
nous revêtir
tous
avec révérence
dans nos actes
dans notre attitude
et même dans la manière
dont on parle
dont on s'habille
on doit prendre
en considération
ce qui est
honorable
c'est un peu
comme l'apôtre Paul
il dit
que si
un lutteur
ne lutte pas
selon les règles
il est disqualifié
il faut avoir
une conduite
honorable
peu importe en soi
appréciable
belle
tout ce qui est juste
la justice
c'est tout simplement
d'être en harmonie
parfaite
avec les normes
absolues
et inébranlables
et intemporelles
ou perpétuelles
des dieux
heureusement
la justice des dieux
est révélée
dans sa parole
surtout dans les dix commandements
mais aussi dans toute la Bible
et nous apprenons
à chérir la justice
par la considération
de combien
cher
a coûté
notre justification
pour qui Dieu
nous déclare juste
il a dû envoyer son fils
pour vivre la vie parfaite
dans notre place
pour mourir
la croix
pour nous
donc la justice
elle est très chère
pour Dieu
et même si nous sommes
justifiés
par une justice
étrangère
aucun chrétien véritable
ne peut négliger
la justice
les chrétiens
ce sont ceux
qui sont les plus préoccupés
à honorer
ce qui est juste
pour ne pas
déshonorer
ce qui Christ a dû payer
pour eux
à la croix
la justice
est loin d'être
les droits
de réclamer
la justice
les chrétiens
qui voudraient
réclamer leur justice
devraient revenir
à l'enfer
et si nous avons appris
que les pardons
des dieux
envers nous
c'était un pardon
infiniment généreux
pour pardonner
nos dettes
on n'essaiera pas
en train de nous permettre
de nous laisser
abuser tous les temps
bien sûr que non
mais il faut qu'on fasse
attention
à ne pas
à mettre
une espèce
de justice
au-dessus
de l'évangile
de la justification
au-dessus
du pardon
si on essaye
à traiter
avec beaucoup
de sévérité
on est en train
de démontrer
qu'on n'a pas compris
l'évangile
la justice
des dieux
c'est important
de considérer
que nous ne pouvons
pas non plus
utiliser la loi
des formes injustes
de trouver des brèches
dans la loi
où on va plutôt
profiter
il y a quelques années
j'ai perçu
quelque chose
qui m'a trop gêné
c'était
même un pasteur
ami
qui nous partageait
en fait
qu'il était en train
d'étudier
pour devenir avocat
et qu'il avait appris
que c'était très facile
de trouver
des indemnisations
des grandes compagnies
des vols
ou d'autres compagnies
les grandes entreprises
elles peuvent
indemniser
très facilement
les clients
qui peuvent réclamer
avoir été
injusticés
ou abusés
le problème
c'est que parfois
on voyait des causes
qu'ils utilisaient
pour chercher
à réclamer
leurs droits
qui n'étaient pas
du tout
des causes
justifiables
ils voulaient plutôt
profiter
du système
et ça c'est de l'injustice
d'autres jours
on était en train
de rentrer la voiture
en sortant
des monoprix
et un de mes enfants
a trouvé
comme un effaceur
qui est
comment jouer
pour les enfants
et elle voulait prendre
car c'était
abandonné par terre
et je pense
que c'est pas très grave
si jamais
quelqu'un les prend
mais je pense
que les principes
sont très importants
et j'ai dit
ma fille peut-être
que c'est pas très
importants
dans notre perception
mais ça peut être
très important
pour un enfant
et ça peut
qu'ils veulent venir
revenir
et vouloir les retrouver
donc on va pas prendre
on va laisser
où tu l'as trouvé
comprenez les principes
justice
il est-il juste
que les enfants
du royaume
payent les impôts
la sensation
c'était
la question
posée
par Christ
à Pierre
c'était
pas forcément
car ils étaient
dominés par Rome
et Rome
avait envahi
ils n'avaient pas
les droits
à la terre
de la promesse
et Jésus va
pêcher les poissons
et trouver
les monnaies
donc là
on va pas laisser
d'occasion
donner à César
ce qui lui appartient
ce qu'il apprend
dans un autre passage
donc bien sûr
on doit être juste
on doit faire justice
être intègre
dans tous les respects
de la vie
tout ce qui est pur
une couche
encore plus élevée
à la justice
car
si la justice
est l'expression
formelle
du caractère
des dieux
en forme
des lois
ce qui précède
à la loi
c'est la piété
notre rapport
envers Dieu
ne doit pas être
toujours basé
tout simplement
sur une loi
externe à Dieu
c'est la loi
de la relation
avec Dieu
Dieu
elle est fondément
ultime
de la justice
de la sainteté
et donc la pureté
des dieux
l'éclat de sa beauté
comme Nath
a bien mis en emphase
à l'entrode
de ses cultes
c'est de rappeler
que l'expression
suprême
de l'éthique
de la beauté
c'est la gloire
de l'éclat
de la sainteté
de Dieu
il n'y a aucune obsession
pour un vrai chrétien
qui soit plus attirante
envers sa joie
qu'il est de se présenter
pur devant cet être
et qu'elle est plus pur
c'est lui qui habite
en lumière inaccessible
le plus grand espoir
pour nous les chrétiens
c'est le jour
où on arrivera au ciel
avec nos corps glorifiés
avec nos âmes glorifiées
étant pur
comme il est pur
soyez sans
car je suis sans
c'est la question
que je dois me poser
est-ce que cette voix
qui est là
est une voix pure
est-ce qu'elle est
une voix limpide
transparente
est-ce que lorsque
je me communique
avec des personnes
il y a une dissonance
entre ce que je veux
donner l'impression
d'être
et ce que je suis vraiment
ce que j'ai ressenti
et ce que j'ai dit
les corps quelque part
il devrait être
tout simplement
une extension
une expression authentique
de nos pensées
et de nos sentiments
donc pas utiliser des masques
c'est l'opposé
de la pureté
avoir un double cœur
comme dit la Bible
les purs des cœurs
verront Dieu
est-ce que ma décision
sera pure
tout ce qui est aimable
et là on pourrait traduire
par doux
bienveillant
généreux
patient
c'est la question
que je dois poser
car je peux chercher
la justice
et la sainteté
comme c'est les contextes
pour certaines églises
légalistes
sont tellement préoccupés
avec la justice
et la sainteté
qu'ils finissent
pour
avaler les chameaux
et
filtrer les moustiques
ou la mouche
ou comme on dirait
au Brésil
tuer une mouche
avec un
canon
des fois on trouve
des personnes comme ça
à l'église
tellement préoccupées
avec la sainteté
qu'ils n'arrivent
à démontrer
aucun amour
aucune douceur
aucune générosité
et ça c'est l'opposé
de la manière
dont le Christ a vécu aussi
c'est la loi du Christ
c'est la symétrie
c'est l'équilibre
et c'est cette manière là
dont on doit vivre
tout ce qui mérite
l'approbation
dans ma conversion
ces mots étaient
un mot très puissant
je sentais que j'avais
perdu mon opportunité
auprès des dieux
car ma mère a cherché
m'évangéliser
quand j'étais petit
et j'avais eu
une connaissance
superficielle
des dieux
de l'église
de la bible
et j'étais écarté
de la foi
et quand je lisais
la bible à nouveau
je voulais revenir à dieux
et c'était ces mots là
qui m'est martelé
tout le temps
l'approbation
et c'est très important
pour nous envers nos enfants
car on sait que
pour plus qu'on ne sera jamais parfait
Dieu nous assure
d'une approbation parfaite
en Jésus Christ
et nos enfants
ont besoin
de notre approbation
constante
et qu'ils aient aussi
besoin de nos reproches
de notre discipline
mais ça
aide nos enfants
à comprendre aussi
cette manière de Dieu
de nous approuver
et donc ici
c'est très puissant
tout ce qui mérite
de l'approbation
si un chrétien
a déjà vécu
cette crise
que tous les chrétiens
devraient vivre
être devant
l'objet suprême
de la gloire
contempler notre
totale indignité
l'impossibilité complète
d'avoir accès à Dieu
d'être réconcilié
avec lui
avoir contemplé
l'objet suprême
de la seule chose
qui peut me satisfaire
selon les demandes
éternelles
de mon âme
et savoir
que c'est impossible
pour moi
d'être approuvé
par Dieu
et d'avoir accès
à sa présence
les jours
où un vrai chrétien
comprend sa conversion
en Jésus Christ
il est pleinement
approuvé en Jésus
il a un pardon
judiciaire
déclaré
cloué à la croix
il n'y a aucune chose
qu'il ne cherche plus
que de continuer
à être
approbable
devant Dieu
vouloir plaire
les pères
le monde entier
peut nous donner
des conseils
de comment on devrait
agir
prendre nos décisions
par contre
la seule question
qui suffit pour nous
c'est
est-ce que Dieu
l'approuve
est-ce que cela
mérite
l'approbation
de Dieu
si la voie
qu'on considère
prendre
c'est une voie
par laquelle
le Christ
ne marcherait pas
si la voie
qu'on considère
prendre
c'est une voie
que Dieu
ne peut pas être
considéré
comme celui
qui l'a ouvert
si il n'y a
aucune autre voie
devant nous
comme David
a dit dans son psaume
c'est lui
qui fait la voie
sous mes pieds
c'est-à-dire
même lorsqu'il
est entouré
par les ennemis
et que je ne vois
aucune sortie
aucune voie
je fais confiance
quand même
qu'il va ouvrir
mais moi
je ne donnerai
aucun pas
dans la direction
d'une voie
qui n'est pas
ouverte par Dieu
s'il n'y a pas
une solution
qui peut être
considérée
comme une voie
approuvée par Dieu
c'est pas
la solution
pour nous
ce sont des voies
inexistantes
pour nous
les chrétiens
ne peuvent même pas
considérer
prendre cette voie
l'autre jour
j'ai entendu
un triste témoin
un témoin très triste
et mon ami
disait
il partageait
ce témoignage
entre nous
il disait
j'ai eu un test
et je n'avais pas
étudié
donc déjà
très mauvais témoignage
mais à la dernière minute
je pense qu'un étudiant
était en train
de chercher
à regarder
les tests
de l'autre
et il a enlevé
cet étudiant
qui était
le plus intelligent
de la classe
et il l'a placé
à mon côté
dans sa compréhension
c'était
la providence
des dieux
qui avait placé
l'intelligent
de son côté
pour qu'il puisse
regarder son test
c'est comme
lorsque Paul
va réprocher
les Corinthiens
votre orgueil
n'est pas bien
vous êtes en train
de vous vanter
d'une espèce
de miséricorde
envers un homme
qui a donné un péché grave
qui ne peut pas être considéré
comme la miséricorde
des dieux
envers cette personne
si ce n'est pas
une voie
qui peut être
ouverte par Christ
elle peut être considérée
pas comme
la providence des dieux
mais la providence du diable
donc s'il y a
quelques vertus
et là on devrait
nous plonger
dans les béatitudes
les fruits de l'esprit
il faut
chercher
à vivre
une vie
virtueuse
s'il y a
quelques louanges
c'est là où on peut
on peut se demander
est-ce que je me sentirais
un hypocrite
en prenant sa décision
est-ce que je peux
véritablement
aller à l'église
et louer Dieu
sachant que je reste
dans ses péchés
si je prends sa décision
est-ce que
ma louange
est accueillie
par Dieu
je ne me sens pas
comme un hypocrite
vous voyez
est-ce que
c'est vertu
est-ce que ça
a quelque louange
est-ce que
cette décision
serait une décision
que si jamais
mes enfants
ou les personnes
qui savent
que je suis un chrétien
dans mon travail
si je prends
cette décision
est-ce qu'ils vont
considérer
comme quelque chose
de louable
que cela
occupe
vos pensées
et l'apôtre Paul
rajoute
malheureusement
on a beaucoup
dépassé le temps
je suis désolé
je vais devoir
m'arrêter ici
on considère ça
la prochaine fois
la leçon c'est que
une pensée
imprégnée
des vertus
des résolutions
si
vous n'avez pas
les temps
qui restent
créez du temps
c'est sommes-nous
à la fin
quelque part
qui allons déterminer
notre agenda
si
on n'a vraiment pas
une autre solution
qu'on dort
un peu moins
qu'on s'est révé
un peu plus tôt
les matins
au moins
en bon repère
avec Dieu
les soirs
aussi
et en chemin
en réflexion
je médite
ta parole
jour et nuit
je ne peux pas
m'exposer
à ces mondes
corrompus
par Satan
de quelle manière
je peux
honorer
ma position
en tant que chrétien
dans cette vie
c'est en occupant
mes pensées
c'est d'imprégner
les pensées
de mes enfants
de ma famille
et c'est ma tâche
je suis
si vous êtes
l'homme de la maison
vous êtes le soleil
de la maison
c'est à vous
de vous sacrifier
le maximum
qui est possible
pour apporter
cette joie
la joie
d'une conduite
sainte
et d'une pensée
imprégnée
de l'évangile
Lloyd John
disait ça
plus que d'être
intéressé
à changer
les comportements
des enfants
il faut que la maison
respire la réalité
de l'évangile
c'est un schéma
quelles sont
les conversations
on va prendre la route
on va déposer
l'enfant à l'école
comment on va profiter
de ces peu de temps
qu'on a
pour imprégner
nos pensées
de la parole de Dieu
vous comprenez
comment vous pouvez
remplir davantage
vos journées
avec les bonnes pensées
refuser vite
les mauvaises pensées
et remplacer
par les bonnes pensées
et on verra
par la suite
que nous avons besoin
non seulement
la théorie
des réflexions
mais nous avons besoin
des répères
et l'apôtre peut
dire ce que vous avez
vu en moi
reçu des moi
pratiquez-le
nous avons besoin
des répères
et si je peux
ouvrir
une parenthèse
envers les
les pasteurs
c'est une chose
qu'il pourra cher
à dire
dans la conférence
nous faisons
en France
moins de 0,01%
des français
les pasteurs
si 0,01%
des français
ne sont pas
en train
de consacrer
le tout
de leur temps
aux pensées
aux résolutions
aux stratégies
aux planifications
aux projets
chrétiens
s'ils ne sont pas
là pour s'aimer
comme il faut
pour être
les modèles
de sainteté
qu'il faut
la tâche
la plus pertinente
qu'on peut trouver
sur terre
c'est la tâche
de la proclamation
de l'évangile
pour produire
le salut des nations
nous ne pouvons pas
rester sans répères
à cet égard
nous avons besoin
de plus d'ouvriers
et plus d'ouvriers
à temps plein
car c'est de revêtir
avec honneur
sa tâche
c'est honorable
de consacrer
son tout
et les tout
de son temps
à ceux
qui ont la tâche
la plus pertinente
l'apôtre Paul
même en prison
consacrait
tout son temps
pour se sanctifier
pour occuper
ses pensées
pour développer
des stratégies
pour la promotion
de l'évangile
et nous devons prier
pour une génération
d'hommes
appelés par Dieu
qui se consacrent
à temps plein
pour les ministères
Amen
Prions
pour la tâche